okay hello everyone welcome to another q
a about history of science and
technology
um on friday i had been doing q a and i
was
rapidly getting sick i'm happy to say i
seem to have been recovered
uh
you know
human one code virus zero i'm sorry my i
after three years no i was last second
2018 so i was a little disappointed to
to finally get sick again but uh seem to
have uh triumphed
um
all right let's see a variety of
questions here
uh blank is asking
saying i recently talked about uh
relearning history of thermodynamics
i ask can ask for resources for learning
history of the dynamics hopefully i will
soon be able to provide one because i'm
going to write something about the
history of thermodynamics probably be a
few weeks out
um
i would say about learning this kind of
history in general
uh
you've got to go back to the primary
sources you know there are a few
summaries of thermodynamic history
which are some of them are not bad
um
but
it's just the amount you learn by just
going back to the primary sources is is
amazingly great and it's always
interesting to see like like i've been
trying to understand
who really came up with the formula ds
equals dq over t the change of entropy
related to the change of heat and so on
well it was kind of rudolph clausius
but he kind of did it in a complicated
way and and then it was kind of other
people and who really established the
second row of the dynamics what were
people thinking about when they
established the second law as opposed to
the first law there's a lot of very
interesting history there and i i also
find that
gotta look at the primary papers if
you're lucky they've been translated
into english
uh at least for me
um you know some languages i can read
but but others i can't
um
the uh um you know and and and sometimes
you have to look at the original
language and and try and piece through
things
uh
you know looking at formulas and other
such things
but
you know i was i was interested to
understand things like the s equals dq
over t and where'd that really come from
and so on and i discovered that the the
best and clearest description of the
stuff that i have found so far
comes in a book called the theory of
heat
by a certain james clerk maxwell
who was a very clear writer very clear
presenter of logic
about what things really mean and so on
i i must say that i've become in this
project i've become very impressed with
james clark maxwell
um and i was already impressed with him
but i was becoming even more impressed
with him
uh it led an interesting life and talk
about it if people are interested in
that i'll i'll probably write about it
when i write about the history of
thermodynamics
it's always interesting to see these
different personalities and and kind of
what they thought they were achieving
you know clausius
was uh uh not as mathematically
sophisticated as maxwell
um
uh but was
you know and all of these people were
sort of uh maxwell was strangely
practical in many ways uh you know as
the person who made the uh what many
people would be considered to be the the
first color photograph for example he
was definitely had a practical bent but
you know you'll find even in his theory
of heat there'll be things where he says
uh you know there's the theoretical
formula you know such such and such but
the actual viscosity of air is blah blah
blah and he says you know viscosity has
been measured by for solids and liquids
to be measured by people including blah
blah blah and for gases including blah
blah and myself he says
and then he quotes his value for the
viscosity of air and so on so it's kind
of an interesting collection you know
correspondence between the sort of the
very theoretical and the quite practical
also interesting that there's a there's
a charming little thing
where um uh clausius has assumed that
all molecules travel at a fixed velocity
at a constant velocity
in
in of course they didn't yet know that
molecules really existed but in their
sort of mathematical idealization of
things the molecules exist they're going
parallel to the the edges of a container
in a way that's very bizarrely similar
to the cellular automata models that
i've studied that they're they're on
kind of a grid
and clausius works out various
properties of of
and things based on molecules traveling
along those grid lines out of constant
velocity
and then maxwell comes along and says no
no i can actually do the calculus and
figure out the whole distribution of
velocity the maxwell-boltzmann
distribution
uh together with molecules going in all
directions and doing all the integrals
and then clausius is very insistent
that um uh no no the really the answer
is i don't know square root of a half or
something and maxwell says really three
quarters maybe i got that the opposite
way around um and uh maxwell observes
rather
rather uh snarkily you know clausius
believes maxwell cannot do integral
calculus
um
and uh
but but in fact he can
now i think
you know
uc boltzmann for example i think was
sort of intermediate and boltzmann was
reasonably mathematically sophisticated
or boltzmann never really believed in
the continuum boltzmann always set up
everything in terms of discrete
energy levels discrete molecules that's
where planck kind of got his ideas
ultimately for quantum theory from was
boltzmann's formalism which i think had
some precursors in clausius which i
haven't really analyzed properly yet um
of of just sort of approximating
everything by discreteness
and uh and then being able to work out
like these formulas for entropy in terms
of discrete counting of states
um but uh
that's some uh
you know i think i think boltzmann was
sort of intermediate uh maxwell's really
the most mathematically sophisticated in
a very cambridge kind of tradition um of
of those kinds of characters although
although subsequently uh well both karat
theodory and gibbs in their different
ways um i guess car theodore was a
little later
gibbs gibbs probably it was also
mathematically sophisticated um although
he took his
his ideas in a slightly different
direction i think one of the things
that's been sort of a horror for the
history of thermodynamics
is that once people realize that things
like you know entropy is a function of
state things like this
then it becomes a big festival of
multivariate calculus and partial
derivatives and things
which is a
a
way of sort of setting up a formalism of
thermodynamics
without really knowing how grounded you
are in terms of the actual physics of
how entropy works and so on and so there
ends up being this very elaborate
mathematical structure that's built
um
that uh
i don't think actually in the end is
really completely justified um but uh
it's sort of uh you know many of the
recent treatments recent by recent i
mean last 50 years treatments of
thermodynamics are very much saying
let's act
assume this or that mathematical
structure and then build from there and
and not even consider what's underneath
that and what the foundations might
really be like
um i think
uh so you know there are a lot of
charming things in this history
in the 1860s which is the real time when
this was very active um there's just a
lot of a lot of interesting interaction
between all these different characters
and uh you know things like um gibbs has
made these physical plaster of paris uh
like surfaces representing sort of um uh
pressure
uh volume temperature etc
kind of characteristic surfaces of
materials and maxwell is then eagerly
sort of making his own version of this
uh similarly actually physically
constructing it and so on um i you know
i'm very i these kinds of things appeal
to me because i'm always very practical
in terms of not me so much you know
making things out of plaster of paris i
don't think i've ever done that but but
um uh you know let's actually write the
code run the things see what it does um
as opposed to just sort of talk about it
and so i have a certain personal uh
affinity to these kind of let's actually
just do it concretely kinds of
approaches to things which as i say the
early demon namicists in the 1860s were
mostly into uh with the exception of
character who was it was much more
theoretical and that's a that's a
separate story
well anyway i probably will have more to
say about uh history of thermodynamics
um soon i'm still
unraveling the whole story um but i'm
getting there
let's see there's a question
here
from igor
can you tell us about the history of
mathematical and computational
linguistics
ones that study principles and
regularities of natural languages there
are famous soviet mathematicians
involved
um
etc
uh yeah i can i can try and i'm not sure
i can try and tell you a little bit
about about the history of this so i
mean the the big question is
uh
kind of
how
is
language has certain regularities
and
what are those regularities and how can
one characterize them
and
certainly uh there were grammarians in
uh ancient rome for sure i think even
some in ancient greece
um
they were describing kind of this is how
sentences look
a very famous example was
um
uh
um
[Music]
what is the name pingala pangolo is that
right
panini panini i'm sorry panini
who was a grammarian of sanskrit and we
don't know exactly when his works were
from but but um
two thousand years ago plus or minus
um
and uh
you know what he was defining was
uh they were defining who knows and i
don't think anybody knows anything about
panini as a person
um
the uh
they were
uh
giving a set of almost aphorisms
that describe possible forms of sanskrit
sanskrit is constructed in out of in
this way this way this way these are
possible sort of sentence type fragments
for sanskrit
uh i i looked at this actually somewhat
recently
and
you know one wonders does one have kind
of a a grammatical pattern
in which it says as we might do today a
sentence consists of a noun a verb a
noun
not quite not as precisely as that
even in those days however people were
concerned about sort of the
mathematicization
of
kind of uh poetry of uh for sort of the
mathematics of prosity of the way in
which uh texts would get kind of scanned
as poetry and so on
and there's a there's a famous thing
from from ancient indian times
of enumerating the possible forms of
prosody which ends up being a story of
fibonacci numbers and ends up being one
of the perhaps the earliest
invention of fibonacci numbers was for
enumerating the number of possible
uh ways in which you could construct
kind of a a a thing with longs and
shorts and so on there could be a
possible form of of uh sort of poetic
meter so that's a that's a very early
example a couple of thousand years ago
um
and again
the idea
that there would be a grammatical
structure to things definitely existed
in antiquity i mean famously lucretius
first century a.d
uh one of my favorite kind of um
early statements of kind of a rule-based
model of the world
was lucretius in his dayrarum natura on
the nature of things sort of epic poem
talks about how
perhaps the world is made of atoms
and the atoms are arranged
much according to rules
much as words are arranged according to
rules the rules of grammar so he's kind
of equating the arrangement of atoms in
the world in the universe
in nature as being sort of like the way
that words are arranged in sentences
according to grammatical rules so
already has this idea of grammatical
rules but doesn't really have a a uh
medium
of of uh to kind of describe those
grammatical rules although as i say the
grammarians i think were mostly giving
kinds of patterns of this is the way
that it's right you know you can say
uh
the um uh
the the cat ate the mouse
but you can't say
uh eats mouse cat or something uh you
know they were saying these are correct
forms these are not correct forms i
think
i actually don't know i realized
recently i don't even know whether
whether there were words for things like
nouns and verbs in in latin um i've not
heard of them but maybe they existed um
so i don't know whether there was that
sort of virtualization that kind of
abstraction that came from the actual
language to kind of a meta description
of the language at that level
but
this whole question about sort of uh
understanding the structure of languages
you know had a very very long history i
mean in in um
uh i think
the um there were sort of different
aspects of different levels of language
from
phonetics to uh you know the
phonetic forms the morphology of words
to kind of the syntax to the semantic
forms to the pragmatic forms and so on
these are sort of hierarchies of levels
of understanding which which evolved in
slightly different ways so for example
you know the brothers grim famous for
their fairy tale collections were
originally
they were philologists they were
collectors of
information about words and so on and in
particular they were interested in sound
shifts
in europe and i guess they went and
visited a lot of different um
um
[Music]
kind of villages and so on and collected
both fairy tales and sounds
and uh were responsible for for grim's
law
uh which is a law about the sort of
evolution of sounds
um in uh in in phonetics and that was a
sort of an early uh kind of
definite statement made about something
linguistic so to speak
i think that um
the thing that uh
uh there were sort of traditions of
linguistics the most famous i guess uh
ferdinand southshore was was one of them
in the 1800s
um
there was kind of a uh i think here's
what i think more or less happened i
mean there you know the languages of the
earth maybe there are seven thousand of
them now unfortunately they go extinct
at some rate maybe at one point there
were ten thousand maybe more i don't
know
um
but at some moment
during the the centuries of colonization
um
one of the sort of things that happened
was that people who had kind of learned
latin and greek and learnt kind of the
idea of structured languages were sent
out to go be the uh the pooh bars of of
colony xyz in different places and there
were there were indigenous languages
there
and those people would often i think it
was particularly a british and perhaps
french
maybe there was some german tradition
there too
um tradition
of you know you're assigned to some
place in india and
you know you were brought up in a fine
british you know school tradition or
something
and you will then write the grammar book
of this of this indigenous language of
that area
and so a lot of those things got
produced and this was particularly
in the
1800s um
mid mid to late 1800s i would say an
awful lot of work was done
of sort of codifying even producing
written versions of languages that
hadn't had a written version um
in the past and that's why a lot of
languages which
you kind of might think were very sort
of outlying languages how could they
possibly have kind of standard english
alphabet well it's because they only got
a written form in you know 1890 or
something when some uh random british
foreign service person was assigned to
the area um but but i think that that
led there to be sort of this big
collection of information about
languages at that time
and and then people were started
to be interested in so what are the
common principles across all these
languages
and
they've been very much this kind of idea
of
sort of this descriptive tradition
of um
of writing grammar books and so on that
existed
the uh the sort of the modernization of
that
big sort of moment of that was in 1956
when both the bacchus nawa formed for
computer languages
and the uh generative grammar idea of
chomsky uh for um and um uh
what's his name
um
chomsky's um
former advisor at university
pennsylvania
oh my gosh
um
[Music]
maybe this is what uh having been sick
for a few days does to me my memory
gets uh blown up here but but um uh
sorry i'm not remembering his name um
the um but in any case this this idea
that emerged
of kind of this sort of formal
description
of a language in terms of this kind of
uh structure this kind of phrase
structure description that the language
is made up of sort of tree structured
things and they're also plug compatible
um that's something that was uh sort of
this more
computational framework was something
that um
[Music]
emerged in 1956
both
in the context of computer languages and
in the context of
of human languages and that kind of then
started this whole
sort of um
you know revolution in linguistics
in which the more descriptive
linguistics that have been done in the
past kind of gave way to this more kind
of formulaic linguistics
um and you know huge wars happened and
new linguistics departments got minted
some of them have now died um but that
was kind of the big transformation there
now into the middle of that
there were
uh there was a there was a tradition
there was also a russian tradition that
the person asking the question was was
mentioning
um i i don't know all of that but um
uh um uh andre komogorov
uh really mostly a probabilist
um one of the things he was very
interested in was was in
uh in language and in studying the kind
of mathematical and probabilistic
structure of language and of seeing uh
sort of how that how language can
can have things put together now one
very famous paper called three
definitions of the amount of information
um which is trying to sort of uh work on
the mathematicization
of uh kind of the information content of
language and you know shannon for
example in uh
the
1948-ish i think had written his
paper about information theory
and had had this
uh sort of p log p definition of
information based on essentially taking
a digital transmission line
and saying break the bits that are being
transmitted like kind of like you know
ones and zeros being transmitted into
blocks and start asking questions about
what the frequencies of different
possible blocks are and so on and i
think you know shannon worked during the
war
on uh uh cryptography and and so on and
i think this kind of idea
of uh sort of a mountain of information
was something very important in
cryptography because if you're trying to
uh find a key of a certain size you just
can't find that unless you have
certain unless you have the appropriate
sort of amount of information it just
you have to that's sort of a baseline
thing that you have to achieve but
uh
shannon
really was thinking about
the transmission of ones and zeros and
so on and not so much about
the meaning of what was being
transmitted now in his in his original
paper
one of the examples he does give is
about the kind of structural redundancy
of english
it's like you've got english letters a's
and b's and c's and you know every time
you have a cue you have it it's followed
by you so there's redundancy every time
you don't really need to record the u
because after the q because you know
it's going to be there and and that
redundancy is is what makes it uh you
know we know that e's are more common
e's are the most common letter followed
by ts and so on that's why in most code
we encode a uh you know an e with a dot
to t with a dash and then you know a z
with a some long sequence of of four
four symbols and so on um and so this
idea
that you could take something like
english
and compress it and ask the question how
much can be it can be compressed
by saying well we'll just use these code
words in most code or we'll omit the u
after every cue and so on how much
compression can you achieve and shannon
argued that it's about 50 percent and
there's a variety of ways you can kind
of see that for yourself like you you
take an english sentence you just start
zapping letters and you see when
up to what point can you as a human kind
of vaguely looking at it still more or
less understand what it's saying
um you could also shannon had a nice
example in terms of
crossword puzzles
um in which uh he says that um if you
you know if you want to have an
n-dimensional crossword puzzle you want
to have it be reasonably dense so you've
got left you know words following it's
you know not you're not just having a
couple of words that cross over and then
the rest of it is all blank space but
you want to have it reasonably dense
then uh for two dimensional crossword
puzzles a half is kind of the critical
redundancy and that's more or less what
you have in english um if you want to
have a three-dimensional crossword
puzzle you need a um
a lower redundancy because in a sense
when you have if you have no redundancy
at all it means that every sequence of
letters is a valid word so you can
always have this kind of a completely
dense crossword puzzle i believe that's
something you can do in chinese if i'm
not mistaken um where you're using
idiogram ideograms rather than rather
than letters
but in um
uh
the the claim would be that you can't
really make a dense 3d crossword puzzle
in english um and uh so so you know that
was another kind of tradition there but
then komogorov was interested in in in
going beyond kind of the pure
uh this is how the letters occur
statistically and saying more about sort
of how what they mean
and that led him to his version of
algorithmic information theory uh my
friend greg chaten had a different
version of algorithmic information
theory in the end they sort of boil down
to the same but the idea is well just
ask the question what's the shortest
program that allows you to generate the
thing you were going to say
um and that short program might be you
know it's pi
and then the thing you generate is all
the digits of pi or it's something that
is going to generate some kind of
textual thing and that's part of that
that work of komographs
but i think
in terms of the history of um
uh computational linguistics
the
there's this first of all there's sort
of the descriptive version
of given
a
uh
given something like a a text and you
know
in karakol pack or something
what is the um
you know how can you describe this is it
do you describe it as you know a phrase
structure grammar and it's got
functional heads and it's got um uh you
know adverb clauses and postpositions
and prepositions and you know all this
kind of structure do you describe it in
those terms
um that's that's sort of one form of
computational linguistics and then
another thing is and can you understand
what it means or translate it into a a
different language and so on by the way
in terms of the the the exploration of
languages i i sort of forgot to mention
that that um in addition to the kind of
the foreign service crowd and so on that
were going out and uh doing kind of
administrative colonization
of um of the world another very big uh
source of linguistic knowledge is
missionaries
um and uh that's been in fact even to
this day
um the sort of the the best collections
of data
uh they called ethnologue for example
that's that was constructed by by those
folk um that's uh sort of a an inventory
of the languages of of um of of the of
the world
um i i did find it interesting i
remember a little while ago tweeting
some of those guys and and seeing some
for some reason some some job ad for you
know uh you know sort of
you know studying linguistics and so on
and um uh you know uh ability to fly
small planes particularly seaplanes an
advantage um you know because you're
gonna be flying up the amazon and
trying to visit folks there who have all
sorts of interesting languages
um
but uh it's kind of a very
action-oriented um profession i think
going into
uh um record
sort of out in the field languages which
which still have not been well recorded
but i think in the um
uh the
that's another tradition and there's a
there's sort of a different piece of
that tradition which is translating the
bible into all possible languages i
don't know how far that's got it's
certainly far from the 7000 languages
that are known but so the first step is
to even find out what languages there
are and where are they and and so on
so
i think uh uh
uh you know it's it's been a thing that
has been something people have been
watching in in recent years is the is
the kind of the extinction of languages
um and endangered languages and so on
and there are a variety of initiatives
to try and sort of save endangered
languages it's a tough business because
there are often languages where
you know people used to speak them the
older people speak them the younger
people are watching television shows
that were made in the u.s or something
and you know they're going to learn
english
and they're going to go off to the
cities and they're going to be doing
things where they're mostly speaking in
english or in whatever language it might
be portuguese or whatever it is um and
uh
they kind of forget the native language
so to speak
and by the time you have few enough
speakers you know by the time you've
only got one speaker of a language it's
sort of all over and um uh the question
of sort of how you preserve
um a kind of endangered language is an
interesting question and you know i know
that people uh someone i know has uh i
don't know what's happened to that
initiative actually had an initiative
based in san francisco area of literally
getting little groups together where
people would learn some of these
endangered languages just to have a
living version of that language um sort
of preserved in some way
but anyway in terms of the history of of
uh sort of linguistics
the um you know there's this whole
descriptive area then there's the whole
area of really make a computer do
something with linguistics and sort of
that that got a big boost in the early
1960s
when there was a big sort of darpa
project
to try to make an automatic translation
system and people at that time were very
big on ai ai was going to you know it
was all going to get solved real soon
it was going to be you know it was just
a question of uh applying computers and
pretty soon we would have artificial
brains
um
and at the time this was sort of middle
of the cold war
one of the big issues was
uh you know people were very worried
about the following scenario it's like
you know soviets and americans get
together
and
the you know the the principles on each
side don't speak the others language so
they have to be interpreters human
interpreters that are interpreting
between them and and you know
uh one leader says
you know
we insist that you remove your
missiles from whatever
and the person who's doing the
interpretation translates that
as uh you know
uh
you rascals you shouldn't do this that
or the other
and um you know the concern was maybe a
whole world war would be started because
some interpreter would mistranslate at
least the nuance of some something that
was said in russian or in english
um and so the idea which in retrospect
doesn't seem that good
um was let's have a machine do the
translation instead
then that way there will be no
possibility of error and no possibility
of an interpreter kind of um throwing
the the world or the war or the race or
whatever
um
so anyway there started this big
initiative to try and do automated
translation it was not terribly
successful um and but that was a big
boost to the whole concept of
computational linguistics the sort of
big
i would say
thing there was what is the target for
computational linguistics you know you
start with a sentence in english
what does that sentence turn into
um is it now what we realized in
building will from alpha we have an
answer the answer is we're trying to
turn it into a symbolic language uh
wolverine language uh computational
language that's the target so when we
say you know how far is it from moscow
to new york
that's turned into geo distance of
entity
you know city new york blah blah blah
and we have a target
and that means it's very well defined
problem to do natural language
understanding but that target really
hadn't existed before
and so there was a lot of very confused
work i would say in my opinion
done
in kind of what's the point of
computational linguistics
and so one thing is for example
generating parse trees being able to say
this sentence can be passed into a noun
phrasal verb phrase a noun phrase and so
on we have a function text structure a
movement language for doing that
i think it is of interest to people for
sort of educational purposes i don't
think it's of that much practical
importance
um but that became sort of a big thing
in computational linguistics
now
you know i have to say i will tell a bit
of a story uh from this is the um when
was this this is probably
1983 for type timescale
i visited a then sort of wanted ai group
uh
and university
and um
they they said to me
uh
you know we're doing a lot of exciting
work here
we have a program that um a program that
does language translation and i'm like
really that's that's very surprising
that's you know this is 1983 or
something and you don't get to do
automated machine translation in 1983 it
just wasn't a thing even close at the
time they said no no we have this thing
uh and it does you know
machine translation said okay great you
know what languages says well from
spanish to english
say okay fine can i try it
it's like i don't know much spanish but
i let me try it say well no actually it
doesn't do just free form translation it
translates stories from spanish into
english
and said okay how long do i have to you
know how long does my text have to be to
represent a story i said well no that
that doesn't really do that either it
translates particular kinds of stories
from spanish into english okay fine well
what do they have to be about
well actually it doesn't even do that
actually it translates one particular
story from spanish into english at which
point i'm like what the heck is this
you know what is the scientific thing
that you learn
from this isn't a system this isn't a
computational system
this is at best
some kind of sort of analysis and that's
what it was was kind of an analysis of
we've got this one story in spanish
here's how we break it down in sort of
computational elements and see what the
corresponding elements are in english i
think that's what it was other either
that or it was just a uh you know it was
kind of a fake project or something um
but it was being done by some of the
leading uh well at least one of the
leading sort of ai groups at the time
but so that was kind of the the state of
the art um at that time and of course
the the modern there was a lot done
on kind of more
uh
some rule-based translation and then
more recently statistical and machine
learning type translation where what
one's doing is to basically learn these
correspondences between languages
uh and having a neural net sort of
interpolate between these languages and
see the correspondences and it's very
convenient that for example uh it's
again a sort of a political source
in the european union for example
there are endless legal documents that
have been parallel translated into all
the different languages of the european
union and that's a great training source
for machine learning systems uh the
other another big sources is computer
manuals there's a consortium that sort
of collects the the all the translations
of different computer manuals into
different languages and uh you know so
there's some language is going to get
left out by all of this but at least you
get a lot of parallel texts that way um
and that's uh
although sometimes perhaps the um the
kinds of translations that you get might
have a certain tinge of either computer
manualism or legalisticism uh you know
or
eu policy
stuff or something to them
let's see
well that was a little bit anyway on the
on the
history of linguistics and computational
linguistics
uh
uh let's see
um
the question here just came in from and
asking about the r programming language
about which i know well a little
um
and what do i think about the science of
statistics in general
um
how similar is ai to statistics okay so
let's talk about statistics
you know statistics originally was
uh sort of numbers associated with the
state
and um
the uh the state as in the state run by
governments and things like that
um
i think what was it john grant right the
bills of mortality in the
1650s maybe
uh was a very early example
of um uh of kind of statistics
and
during a plague in london
he did this grim thing of um uh sort of
tallying up the dead
and giving
percentages you know what fraction of
people
uh maybe it wasn't even during the
plague no i i think it was but but um
you know it's a thin booklet and it has
kind of statistical data
on
uh kind of you know this person died of
this that person died of that that
person was this age when they died and
so on
um and in this borough of london this
this person you know this happened and
that happened so that was an early
example of kind of um sort of tallying
things up statistically
now i guess that also
in the 1600s through the particularly
the bernoullis
um there was sort of early ideas about
probability
and
somewhat i think driven by games of
chance
and trying to figure out odds and games
of chance and so on this kind of the
notions of probabilities started to
arise
but then
when it came to the analysis of data
uh
i think that came that really a lot
later i mean people like gauss for
example
when gauss was doing astronomy
and you know he discovered the asteroid
series
um
the uh
uh one of the things gauss did was to
look at sort of errors in observation
and that's how he ended up with the
gaussian distribution um was sort of
quantifying
the the errors of observation and this
was mid-1800s or so um
that uh
that he that he noticed
now things didn't really get i think
more organized in terms of statistics
i mean there had been
um
[Music]
there had been people who had made kind
of digests
about the world that were sort of of a
statistical nature like playfair as a
famous person who did that in the 1800s
um the statistical breviary i think it's
called
um is uh is kind of a summary
of you know lots of charts of the um the
price of this versus this and the um the
size of
this the population of this country
versus that one and so on
but that was more kind of descriptive
sort of these are the numbers and these
are some actually pretty good charts
that playfair has
um that that represent those things
i think the
origination of more sort of inferring
things from numbers
um is something came a little bit later
i mean gauss was early to that game with
the gaussian distribution and so on um i
think that uh the the real sort of uh
flowering of that came in the 1920s and
1930s
with the development of agricultural
research
um and particularly people like fisher
and um uh and so on
who uh in england
were doing were studying the question of
of how should you best breed crops
how should you make more efficient how
should you create more efficient crops
people have been worried that you know
the world would run out of food if there
wasn't if the amount of
food production per acre was not
increased and so that was uh well how
can you do that what you know what
traits would be good for crops and so on
and so people started uh in fact there's
a place near where
i lived where i was a kid actually that
was a the um uh
the roth hempstead experimental station
which was a place where there would be
pieces of fields um where people would
you know on this piece of the field you
put this fertilizer on this piece of the
field you would put this
type of
seed and so on and then you you'd
measure from these little patches of
field you know which one grew faster
which one
uh didn't and and so on
and i think uh
uh that was
kind of the the development of a sort of
mathematics around that
which happened in the 1930s that was
kind of the origin of a lot of uh what
unfortunately one still would say is
modern statistics now
talking about statistics features of the
state i mean another big piece of that
was
censuses and the us
was surely the leading country in terms
of of um
of having a census efficiently done
um and that was you know since the the
concept of taking a census was kind of
burnt into the the uh the constitution
of the us
um that was something that sort of the
u.s has taken seriously i mean there
have been censuses done
uh for a long time i mean you know
whenever people tried to
to levy taxes they would take censuses
and that happened certainly in antiquity
and you know in england for example the
doomsday book
from um
whenever 1080 or something a.d
um
is an example of some kind of census
um but the us was certainly the most
organized census taker i think um
but again i think that census was more
like well how many people are there here
not
let's make a statistical prediction
based on this that really was something
that was more came out of this kind of
agricultural research
side of things
and so what got invented then well uh
things like the analysis of variants and
over
uh things like well i think the the
student t distribution from gosset
who
went under the the pseudonym student
uh you know all of these things the f
ratio distribution all of these
different sort of uh tests i hate these
things by the way so to make no mistake
i i you know as far as i'm concerned by
the time things descend into
we're going to use this very elaborate
statistical technique to tease some
actual
uh structure out of this data you've
lost the game in my opinion the the the
chance of that being significant is is
low
um but you know that whole tradition is
what led to
sort of the the current practices and a
lot of medical research of you know p
values and all this kind of thing um
came out of that agricultural research
in 1930s and so on
i think what then happened was
by the 1960s people were starting to use
computers seriously to do to automate
those kinds of techniques and there were
early
spss the statistical program for the
social sciences developed in chicago
um i think norman nye was the developer
that if i remember correctly that was in
the 1960s
and that was something that was
developed you know on mainframe
computers and kind of the idea was take
all these things that have been done by
people like fisher with uh uh you know
with mechanical calculators and put it
on a computer and put all these obscure
statistical tests on a computer and have
a big inventory of you oh yes my my
favorite test is the such and such named
test let me now implement that on a
computer and so that that kind of thing
got done
um spss as a it was a company and
eventually got bought by ibm many years
later but um it uh
uh
it was
there was a certain i think in the 1960s
and early 1970s a lot of kind of survey
taking um it was a big sort of thing of
survey taking a lot of kinds of fields
whether in politics or in marketing
and that sort of a lot of that fed into
spss
i think also spss in some way managed to
get oh no that was sas that was a
subsequent subsequent product i think
became significant particularly because
it provided some analysis of the flow of
data through mainframe computers as
another sort of application of
statistics and that happened to be
something that people kind of needed on
big mainframe computers
but those those systems
uh
i mean eventually started to get
connected to graphics
and in a sense that was sort of the next
big epoch of statistical
analysis
and one that i think is much healthier
which is rather than the weird name test
that came out of a paper from 1942
is
just plot your data in a reasonable way
and uh
um
and and see whether you can see certain
effects or not
and it became so much easier by the time
kind of
computer graphics became sort of a
routine thing and that didn't really
happen
well when did that really happen i mean
i first used
sort of computer graphics so so okay
when i first used computers
in the mid-1970s
uh it was still the case that the
typical plot that you made
um you would get data from a computer
and i would by hand take those numbers
and plot them on graph paper
now then you started being able to
display plots on line printers
it wasn't really that a line printer
couldn't display a plot as such because
a line printer was just displaying
a kind of character-based data
and then then there were tektronix
oscilloscope scope
display scopes where you could sort of
draw an arbitrary curve
that was something that had already
existed i think by the early 70s
and then there started to be i remember
the printronix printers which were dot
matrix printers that were kind of like
line printers but you could address
every dot on the page and so then you
could draw these actual uh graphical
lines
um and then
uh another technology was pen plotters
um i certainly used those where you were
again xy pen plotters you were
addressing the the position but but
there was a great tendency i think for
those things well no actually i by let's
see by 1978
i was definitely using
uh pen plotter type output as a way to
do visualization of sort of statistical
type distributions and and plotting
things like histograms and so on with
pen plotters um and i think you know
that was sort of the next big thing was
in 1980s and so on was this idea of of
just use visualization don't don't try
to assign the number 3.7 to your data
instead just look at your data and see
are there three lumps in your data or
not and i consider that a much sort of
healthier approach although sometimes as
things get more sort of uh regulatory
and so on it's more like you've got to
have a number you know what is your
number type thing
i would say that what's happened in um
uh
in okay in ai
uh some aspects of
modern machine learning and so on
is very
uh related to statistics i mean it's
it's very you know
what one's doing in a sense is is sort
of giant interpolation of high
dimensional data and so on what one's
doing in things like anomaly detection
is things which are fairly traditional
statistics kinds of questions uh you
know in but the framing is a bit
different the methods are a bit
different mostly
um
and uh
there are places where there's overlap i
mean there's decision trees or an
example of something sort of show up in
both in both areas um i think some of
the um uh
um
[Music]
yeah i mean
one doesn't see
you know it's not like people say it's a
cat
and with a chi squared of such and such
people say you know it's not the kind of
thing that comes out of a machine
learning system there are ways of doing
uh various kinds of um
well what was the most significant
feature
in the image that led you to conclude it
was a cat things like this
but but in a sense the the the tradition
of statistics yeah i think this is an
important thing to say
there are the tradition of of standard
statistics 1930 style statistics
is there is an underlying distribution
it's a gaussian or something
there is that is reality in some sense
we get certain samples from that
population of data it is our job to try
and find the parameters of the sort of
ground truth by sort of fitting things
and
and that's what the role of statistics
is now that sort of assumes that the
underlying is a gaussian
or whatever
and
it
then and it also assumes that there's a
as a representation of the world in
terms of what's essentially a formula
and
you know gaussians are popular the
central limit theorem says they are uh
sort of the thing that arise in many
cases but they're certainly not
everything that can arise and no doubt a
lot of silly mistakes have been made in
statistics from sort of assuming that
everything is a gaussian when it's not
but the fundamental assumption is things
are fit by a formula there's a
distribution it's determined by a
formula
now the thing one realized subsequently
is programs are a better model for many
things in the world than formulas are
but so then you have the question well
let's say you're trying to fit the
parameters of a program to data how do
you do that
that's something was interested in from
my own work
in the behavior of simple programs and
you know given this data what simple
program corresponds to this data those
kinds of questions um but in some sense
you can think of sort of the deep
learning machine learning neural net
world as being answering a very specific
version of a find me the best program
that fits this data
you know it's interesting and well from
language for example we have a function
called learn distribution which can
learn the distribution of anything
images
sounds whatever else
it learns these you know that you can
learn there is a concept of distribution
not just for numerical data like in the
gaussian but among the space of images
for example and that's something which
with sort of modern machine learning you
get to address but by the time you're
saying learn distribution you have many
of the same issues that you have in sort
of traditional statistical distributions
you know you can find random variants
you can find
effectively confidence intervals you can
find um oh boy we have a great name for
this and i've now forgotten it
the um
the probability
given a distribution
and given an instance of a thing
what is the integrated probability of
everything less likely than that thing
so in other words how outlying is that
thing if we learn the distribution of
cat images how unlikely is this picture
of a cat with a crown or something
um and uh that that characterizes that
anyway so that's a little bit about
statistics
um
let's see
uh
ethan asks about the ai art revolution
that's taking place was there a time
like this you know this whole question
about computers
that um
create
artistic forms
is
it has a very long history going right
back pretty much to the beginning
of computing
of uh
um let's
you know produce something that has
artistic output i mean even you know ada
lovelace writing about these things in
1840s um
was talking about some uh
the possibility that computers might
sort of compose music and you know she
has this great quote about how
the the analytical engine you know
weaves algebraical patterns
as the jacquard loom weaves patterns of
birds and flowers
but she had the idea already of using
sort of algorithmic processes to produce
musical forms
um
that
i mean one might argue that
composers like bach and so on um you
know had sort of some algorithmic ideas
but obviously not using computers as
such
um and the the elect the mechanical
computing devices were were numerical
ones for the almost without exception
i mean i suppose that one could think
about
um
i don't know if anybody did this but but
certainly the automata that existed from
the 1600s on of of the little uh you
know figurines doing things and so on
and the music boxes and things like this
one could imagine those is a little bit
like kind of algorithmic generation
musical form although they i think were
very specific mostly of having a a very
particular kind of um uh you know
card-like
uh um
way of of specifying musical notes that
didn't didn't have any possibility of
sort of creativity
but as soon as they were when there
started to be computers there started to
be the possibility of of creating
artistic forms with them i remember the
first computer i used 1972
uh
this thing called the elliott 903
um i think i even wrote some code that
oh okay so one one feature of the
computer was that it had a tone
generator it's something that sort of
got lost in subsequent generations of
computers but as it was it would whistle
while it worked so to speak and as it
was processing data it would be
[Music]
it would make all kinds of noises um it
was never completely clear to me what
those noises came from and i looked in
its documentation to figure out you know
what generated the noise and i don't
think it ever said and i really should i
should ask somebody there are still
people who are enthusiasts of the
elliott 900 series computers um
and uh
i should i should finally find out what
what did the noises come from because
because what i did was i sort of
empirically figured out based on
actually running tight loops in code
okay that tight loop makes this sound
this loop makes that sound and depending
on the tightness of the loop you can
make a different uh uh different pitch
of sound
but you know i i don't think i had
anything very profound but i certainly
made things that would generate sort of
some semi-random sequences
of um uh of musical forms
um
so that was definitely a thing
and um it was uh the idea that computers
might be able to like computers music
and so on definitely an own thing you
know in 2001 space odyssey
there's uh there's sort of a scene of of
uh how the computer um kind of um
uh
you know showing sketches it's made and
things like this no no maybe it's it's
it's commenting on a sketch somebody
else made but i think it has
does it create art it does something
it has some it makes a tune or something
like that i'm i'm forgetting slightly um
but um
in any case it um it's definitely a
known idea there were
composers i think zanakis was one of
them who were quite into sort of
algorithmically generated music i think
even used some things from came out of
my sort of cellular automaton uh
investigations for that
um
in
uh
in music composition
uh for example we had this little
project in 2007 gowar from tones which
is used cellular automata to make
uh pieces of music
that are kind of interesting if you only
um
you know at least for um
for 15 seconds or so
and i've been told that it's a pretty
good source for people who want kind of
compositional inspiration so to speak
there are also sort of different
traditions of taking sort of existing
music classical music for example and
saying let me sort of grind that up into
pieces and reconstitute it and use that
as a
statistically constructed sort of bach
like piece of music that was a different
tradition that tradition is probably
more like the tradition we're seeing now
in terms of uh kind of visual and i've
seen less music actually along these
lines but but visual scenes where
basically one is sort of grinding up the
uh uh the visual scene
and um and saying we can reconstitute it
um to have uh you know to be something
that is a reasonable
uh guess for what a sort of full picture
might be like
um but in terms of this idea
i mean one has seen computer art
of various kinds forever and ever and
ever
and
this concept that it is sort of
derived from these distributions that
effectively come from the real world i
think that's kind of a newly doable
thing
i think that's not something that's been
possible before in the past sort of the
computer art so to speak has been much
more take things that are mathematically
defined for example
and be able to and add some randomness
to that
and then say this is the thing we're
producing you know there's a sort of
seed of randomness and then there's a
whole sort of development that is
mathematically defined and that's the
artistic form whereas what we're seeing
now is there's a seed of randomness but
the development
is more in this sort of uh ground-up
interpolation of real-world scenes
um and so so yeah i think that's a sort
of a i think that's kind of a new thing
i'm trying to remember whether there are
previous versions of this that um that
one's seen i mean certainly
there are
uh kind of you know in in
from the sort of the photoshop style
of uh of image processing
it's been the case that they've been
sort of um uh fill in
things where you're sort of uh filling
in a piece of a scene to sort of follow
that thing that was supposed to be a
picture of a tree but that part of the
tree got cut off and now you want to
fill it in again that's been a thing for
a decade-ish um but now it's kind of
like just take the whole picture and say
i want a tree and uh and you can sort of
generate that uh from uh on its own now
you know i have to say
some of these things that i see uh uh
you know i kind of it's like well it's
very cool it's a very good demo it's not
quite as impressive you know it's like
like look i could just do a web search
for pictures of blah and i would get a
bunch of pictures
and now the question of how they merge
together that knitting together that
interpolation together that's kind of
interesting um
and uh
you know the the the just do what we'd
expect kind of thing is working really
very well in many ways although
you know i i don't know i i
i it's hard to know what the definition
of success is
because is the definition of success we
like the picture or the picture
kind of is a is a a sort of a fake that
that passes muster for some particular
thing or what i mean for example you
know some a little while ago somebody
was was telling me about the the wonders
of i think gpt3 text generation system
and uh was showing me some sort of
simulated conversations between
uh various sort of
scientists of old and so on i'm just
looking at it and it's like this is kind
of cool and you know it's it's
reasonably you know
maybe it's it's reasonably convincing i
said can you do one of these for me
there's you know there's there's enough
of me on the web and you know texts from
me and so on that you should be able to
get a pretty accurate language model for
me and so they did that and then there's
a thing you know answering questions as
me and i look at these things and
frankly i thought they were terrible
now you know i couldn't tell they were
terrible if they were answering
questions like i don't know
girdle might have answered questions or
something because you know i know a
certain amount about actually even that
one i might have been able to tell but
but um i think it was was people where i
didn't really know their style very well
and but by the time it was trying to
imitate me and i sort of know my style
for better or worse it's like this is
terrible it sounds you know it's it's
it's rambling i might ramble but it's
it's rambling off in all kinds of
directions and it doesn't really there's
no thread of the points and so on and
and it really it's it's saying things in
ways that i would never say them and so
on and so on and so on so you know from
a distance it would look fine but from
close up it really didn't look very good
at all and i think the same is often
true of these visual constructions
they're very interesting and they're
very uh they're kind of like you know
there's certain a new generation of art
that will be produced this way um but
you know one of the issues always with
artists so in a sense what's the
um
you know
in some sense what's the point and if
the point is human uh
sort of satisfaction engagement whatever
else
that's a fine point um but it's hard to
measure that very precisely it's hard to
say we achieved you know
nine out of ten for our art
um that's hard to it's hard to quantify
in that kind of way
oh my there's all kinds of interesting
questions here and i'm
about to get to
i'm going to have to go back to my day
job i think we have another live stream
uh coming up about day job kinds of
matters
um
there's a question here from david let's
see if i can
talk about this one now and there's a
lot of other interesting ones here that
um i should attack another day
david asks what did henry poincare
think about the infinities considered by
cantor hilbert and zamello
do engineers need the concept of a
complete infinity
i do not know what pancreas had to say
about cantor
uh he certainly must have been aware of
him and uh
zamelo was was surely very much in that
orbit i mean zanello was in switzerland
poincare was in france
uh
cantor was in
germany
um
but
and this was all happening
1880s 1890s
uh that kind of time frame
um
i don't know uh
i think
i mean
poincare
in a sense cantor
there's a certain thread of development
towards the sort of formalism of
mathematics a sort of formalistic view
of mathematics that goes from people
like fraga
to people like whitehead and russell and
hilbert um
and cantor was sort of a sideshow to
that but not really a mainstream part of
that
poincare was very much against that
and thought of mathematics as as i began
to think of it now as i've sort of been
studying the physicalization of
metamathematics
of mathematics more as a sort of a high
level kind of humanistic level
activity uh far away from the kind of
formal level of axiomatic structure but
i think you know kanto was really a
different branch there i mean in a sense
cantor
in the end
uh mathematical logic
uh sort of connected with cantor but it
was not its earliest part
um and um
i think that kanto
and his notion of transfinite numbers
and so on
it's always been an interest because one
of those things where it was invented in
the 1880s and
you know it's now 140 years whatever it
is
and the question is
did it matter
to things that people in practice do
because people often think you know
mathematics that is aesthetic enough
will end up having an application before
before too long but transfinite numbers
it's not clear what application they've
had i have to say that that um
uh
well
i've been interested in applying
transfinite numbers but the the history
there
has been that in set theory for example
transfinite numbers are yes i mean okay
so i yeah that's right the the the real
the emergence of
trans-finite numbers meets mathematical
logic that really happens in set theory
which is not surprising because cantor
invented set theory um that was uh you
know cantor was originally studying the
somewhat prosaic
question of the convergence of
trigonometric series if you have a sum
of sine
of you know
square root of blah blah blah blah blah
blah sign this that the other what is
the region of convergence of that
of that series when you sum it to
infinity um as a function of parameters
and cancel realized that you could have
really complicated regions of
convergence and so on and it was from
that that he invented
set theory and and transforming numbers
came out of that and so canto was the
originator of set theory and set theory
got entrained in this whole kind of
formalization of mathematics although in
the earliest
versions of things um uh
it it you know there were sort of logic
was one branch piano arithmetic things
like that another branch and then set
theory which had come out of and was
deeply related to in its upper reaches
was deeply related to transfinite
numbers
but now you can ask the question did
transparent numbers as such
end up being something that was
important for um
uh
um
uh for practical
sort of um uh
things in in in mathematics the answer
is
important in set theory lots of
discussions about you know large
cardinal axioms and things lots of
theoretical discussion
um
the
in terms of
and did it matter for building rockets
or something um
the answer
uh to date
has been i think no
i mean there was a claim for a little
while that in high frequency trading
people were using transformative numbers
but i think that was more a um a decoy
than it was reality
um i think that the uh
uh
for myself the thing we've been
interested in for awesome language is we
have lists finite lists of you know the
list x y z one two three whatever
now what happens if we have an infinite
length such list
are there different kinds of infinity of
the length of that list
and how do we know whether two infinite
lists have the same length and if it is
an infinite list but it's an infinite
tree how do we compare infinite trees to
infinite lists this i think leads one
into sort of stories of transfinite
numbers and perhaps in the next few
years we'll actually have a a sort of
practical
uh symbolic version of transfinite
numbers that one will be able to uh sort
of that will end up being of practical
use where we'd actually have a you know
a trans finite omega or something as a
symbol just like we have the symbol
infinity in in well from language but in
terms of of uh to my knowledge to date
uh none of that stuff has had direct
engineering consequence i mean there's
been sort of attempts to say
let's do validation of things like
blockchains and so on on the basis of a
logic that's ultimately sitting on top
of set theory but i don't think that's
gotten that far
um it's it's sort of an interesting but
very distant possibility and it won't
solve the problem of of saying you know
oh we base everything on set theory so
then we've solved all of the kind of
governance problems of blockchain hardly
that's sort of a different branch it's a
different different set of objectives
that are being being achieved there
all right
well
uh should wrap up here
i think i can tell that my um i'm
probably sounding uh
um
uh
not my usual um
uh quite
um
uh my usual
voice pattern and so on i suspect it's
the uh the tail of the viruses and so on
although
they don't seem to be that serious
um
but uh
uh well thank you for a lot of
interesting questions and i see a lot
more and i look forward to continuing
another couple of weeks some when we get
back to uh that part of our cycle of
live streams
and as i say i'm i'm about to go off and
do a day job live stream for those who
are interested in that in just a few
minutes
so thanks for joining me and
bye for now